[Music]
on saturday a group of white
supremacists calling themselves the
patriot front marched through washington
dc carrying american flags and chanting
reclaim america and the demonstration
was caught on video
switch brings us to a segment called
some petty observations
[Music]
this group is dangerous and
anti-american but also
can we talk about their complete lack of
rhythm look at this
yo what is happening what are you doing
what are these people stepping on the
ones and sevens
that is the sloppiest beat i have ever
heard in my life it sounds like he
picked up the sticks and then just
dropped them on the drums
the sounds they made are the sound
that they're going with
these guys they were protesting america
and across the street a group of
metronomes was protesting them
flopping around flopping like a bunch of
right-wing scarecrows f come to life
also now conservatives want to wear face
masks this photo is more hypocritical
than a vegetarian eating a meat lover's
pizza
those aren't even good face masks it
looks like you were putting on a shirt
and you accidentally put your face in
the sleeve hole
also you're trying to intimidate people
and the best outfit you could come up
with was the uniform from blockbuster
video
what are you trying to intimidate me
into doing rewinding
this is the most pathetic display of
tough guy attire i have ever seen this
guy is not sure if he wants to
ethnically cleanse america or slide into
first
and check out this man's homemade shield
where did you get that
he-man's etsy shop to fix them to do are
you fixing to fight or sled down a hill
[Music]
look the rise of white supremacist
groups in america is a serious problem
according to the adl racist propaganda
is at an all-time high in our country we
should take these groups seriously but
that doesn't mean we shouldn't also make
time for some petty observation
now there's one more important news
story i want to talk about tonight
the makers of kool-aid recently issued a
recall for the beverage because it may
contain pieces of metal and glass here
to comment please welcome the kool-aid
man
[Music]
hey amber happy to be here
kool-aid man where are you
i'm behind this wall
oh well are you gonna do the thing
what thing
the thing where you crash through it
oh yeah
no
but
that's what you're known for it's your
signature move you crash through the
wall and you yell oh yeah
oh so you think the only way for
kool-aid to be entertaining is to break
through walls and carry on like a
buffoon well sorry you will have to find
a different beverage to make you a fool
oh
i'm sorry i didn't mean to offend you
you just it's just
always been my dream to see this happen
in real life
no
you know what i'm sorry
i'm just really stressed about this
recall it used to be that when you
thought about kool-aid you thought about
having fun but now i'm associated with
danger
this recall is ruining my reputation and
i'm stressed
well if it makes you feel better i still
think you're fun
you do yeah when i think of you i think
of summertime and birthday parties than
lemonade stands i think of good times
really really and i bet a lot of other
people feel the same way
wow
you see i thought things were over for
me oh no way kool-aid man i think
they've just begun
you're right
this recall isn't going to bring me down
i'm going to prove to the world that i
still got it here i come
[Music]
kool-aid man
kool-aid man
are you okay
oh no
[Applause]
well at least he died doing what he
loved
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you